hello everyone so my name is Lefteris i
am a postdoc at EPFL and i'll be
presenting particle four fully a single
distributed generation this is what I
did this summer at whim were working
with Dalia and Sasha
so although we already had a talk
yesterday about how awesome distributed
generation is and why we need it we have
kind of a different motivation which
comes from the latest gossip on partial
signals and fully synchronous concerns
protocol so if we look in all the papers
published in the last couple of years
who get protocols that are very
efficient for example there is SB of T
which is a prac is a partial synchronous
distribute concerns protocol that is
linear the common case and only
quadratic when you do a few trains then
we get hot stuff which is a different
trade of 12 HP which is almost linear it
plays a bit more latent in the common
case but it scales very well and there's
also Bubba which is a fully a
synchronous consensus protocol which is
inspired by hot stuff
and it actually achieved the
theoretically optimal quadratic
communication complexity all these
problems have a trusted set of
assumptions which means that there needs
to be a delay at the beginning of the
protocol who is going to disperse some
cryptographic material to everyone else
in order for those protocols to be
efficient and actually for Bubba to even
work which means that if your trusted of
certain breaks if the dealer gives the
correct material to the adversary then
the product was completely broken so
what we did in this work is we actually
remove this trusty setup and instead put
distributed booster cells that can
generate this to the guard material in a
decentralized way so I know that
Evernote sharing so it
works on polynomials I'm not going to
discuss much about how it works there is
some basic reserving which is the first
one that was pretty was is the first
secret sharing protocol and it needs an
honest dealer then we have the fabric
secret sharing where the idea is that we
use cryptographic commitments on the
polynomial in order to for the parties
to verify that they're on the consistent
polynomial and they don't get random
shares and then there is a single very
fabric of sharing which is built to
actually work in a fully single network
and well the idea is that we secret
share the secret shares so that part
that were slow can come later and
collect their search from the rest of
the network and what can we do with this
secret sharing protocols and what is
useful in consensus first we can do
press for signatures which means that we
can generate signatures from the whole
group of the consensus collectively
which are constant in size so this is
why the protocol scales and also if the
signature scheme that we use - you can
mix signatures just like we saw in the
previous talk we can use that to produce
randomness so why we use these protocols
in consensus the idea is if you look
into class computing protocol we have a
leader till the access ramp repair
commit and the idea is that when some
ask you to commit for example the
parties will send the signature yes I
commit here is a signature that I did
what I said the leader will collect all
those signatures put them together and
then broke up the back to convince
everyone that everything happened
correctly and that message is linear in
size as a result linear size message to
willing the number of protocol of
parties we have quadratic complexity so
what s 15 host has do is in the same
kind of protocol the parties used their
secret sir in order to sign their
commitments for example and the leader
is going to combine all those signatures
in a constant size signature which is
mentioned back as a result this works in
the linear case as I said if the dealer
was malicious then here the safety is
broken because he knows the actual
threshold key as a result he can sign
whatever
you want to the threshold key and
convince everyone that something
happened that actually did not in a
synchrony we use it for the same thing
for compaction as before so if the
dalish melissa safety is broken again
and we also use it to comment at SLP
because it's used a in order to produce
some randomness in the system some
strong common coin as we say it which
basically defends against the adversary
the ordering the messages so even if we
don't want it for scalability in the
synchrony we actually alternate for
liveness
as a result we it's very important in
the synchronous case so of course every
time someone says you have a trusted
party and with no interested party the
idea is less decentralized protocol
let's make everyone do it and this is
the idea of the stable d-generation
protocols every part is going to secret
share some random value some private
public key that they generate and
they're going to send their success the
Runnels party they will do the same
party 3 the same but for the same then
we add them all together and we say that
the addition is the collectivity so as
long as one of those parties leader
correctly everything is perfectly random
and that can work in a synchronous
environment but in the synchronous we
might have malicious party that might
not reply so then we go to the we can't
wait for all of the parties to reply and
then decide which are malicious we have
wait for n minus F but with send - apart
right we're in a signal space so the
adversary might actually be replying to
us and slowing down some other nodes so
it seems that we kind of need consensus
we need to decide on which part is
actually the correctly in order to boost
our consent how we solve that well in
literature there is a protocol called
fabric eg and I guess also the protect
protocol that basically employ a parsing
of consensus in order to bootstrap this
decision process the problem is that
they can only have a threshold of F plus
1 which is not enough for a verb and hot
stuff and also there is a quick
sigourney assumption as a result if you
want it for a freshman's protocol then
you need either a initial
assumptions of some synchrony or it
doesn't work synchrony pbft works in
order for publicity to raise consensus
in order for pbft protocol stories
consensus there needs to be a point in
time at which all methods are guaranteed
to be delivered within some unknown bomb
Delta it's an unknown part of synchrony
maybe it's it's unknown that's why we
constrained but it's not a strong signal
or something meaning that there it is
not unknown Delta bound in strong signal
and we know what the Delta is we
designed the protocol assume that Delta
holds so in order to solve the first
problem we have to look into what we get
from the trusted setup and what we need
for consensus so in the dusty setup if
we secret share a threshold key that has
a threshold of 12 + 1 that means that
our key is safe even if two of the
parties are malicious
we cannot reconstruct the key even if to
have parts analysis however the keys
live only if at most personal malice is
because you have a place on personal
issues you cannot collect enough shares
however in consensus we don't really
need that what we need is our say T to
be safe as long as at most F parts and
malicious if F plus some parts are
malicious consensus in their synchronous
broken already so we don't care about
having a high threshold and as before
the key has to be live in the same case
so the threat models do not match and
this is what we actually take advantage
of in order to increase the threshold so
the idea is that we are going to
separate the safety from the liveness
dress codes of the protocol so that they
match the quorums that consensus needs
so the key will be safe only if you have
at most left parties a malicious and it
will be live as long as to have plus one
honest parts participate
just like in consensus how do we do it
basically we're going to use
two dimensional secret sharing so this
is usually done with bivariate
polynomial but we're not going to use a
symmetric Boveri polynomial we're going
to use Mathematica over a polynomial in
the first dimension we put a high
threshold the to f plus one through
school so if there is secret s we are
going to create four secret shares and
you need three out of four in order to
collect in order to reconstruct the
secret then on the y axis we're
basically going to sequester its secret
cell with a lower threshold so in order
for s1 to be reconstructed you need any
two out of four of this y11 y12 etcetera
and then we're going to run a navy SS
very similar to what if this entire work
so let's walk a bit rate what happens at
the dinner is going to generate this
bivariate polynomial and then he is
going to send a row and the column at
this party so party one will get the
first run the first column party do will
get the second row and the second column
etc and in this case we have partying
and party to that are honest party
threes malicious but participating and
party for here is slow it's not getting
anything including the dealing phase so
we have the Dalek face the dealer is
going to send the rows and the columns
that parts are going to cross check that
everything is fine they're going to
participate correctly all three are
honest for the dealing phase so the
result is that s1 and s2 have the whole
Roman columns s3 has them but is not
going to participate later on so if we
go now and try to reconstruct the secret
we can't write we have this one will
have this true s3 is not replying s4
doesn't know anything so in order to
resolve that what happens is that when
s4 eventually comes alive it can go and
ask a party one in party to for these
cells and because they've sent the they
have the whole row they can send it back
to it and see do have we only need two
out of four in this dimension it can
reconstruct the secret cell for and then
we have there the following we can
reconstruct a full secret
so what are the guarantees that we get
from this ABS first its liveness meaning
that if the dealer is honest throughout
the protocol then everyone who's going
to have codex the cursors and agreement
which means that even if a deal is
malicious but there is no nice party
that decided at some point that the
secret sharing is done correctly then
every honest party will also collect
correct secret shares eventually and
actually this is good enough to boost
our hot stuff we can just plug it into a
hybrid EKG and the rest is the same yes
the problems are the same there is
nothing new just well we put the Tressel
higher so now you can have a secret
sharing scheme that needs to f+ one
secrets to record shares to reconstruct
the secret the the problems are exactly
the same it's just we need to actually
modify this proof in order to work again
with the high dress code but the
properties are exactly the same okay so
that's how we can bootstrap a person
since protocol in order to be efficient
however of course we wanted to solve the
biggest challenge and I'm trying to I
will try to explain some parts but it's
fairly complicated it had like five
layers I explained this one and I'm
actually going to explain the two that I
think are the most interesting which is
there would be silky generation and
eventually a common coin the rest you
can probably also figure out on your own
if you see what works here
so in which generation just like and
civic regeneration we have the parties
every part is going to secret share a
value using our 8a BSS scheme and what
it's week first of all because it has no
termination guarantee like we cannot say
that the decade is exceeded at any point
in time it will eventually succeed if
you wait forever but we don't really
know when that happens that's why we
call it week so how does it work every
particular search and then they collect
secret shares from everyone else and
basically when this
at least two f+ one of the parties did
their job correctly they are going to
just broadcast a vector saying here this
to f+ one party's did their job
correctly that's my belief if they see
more parties finishing they can
broadcast a bigger vector so there might
actually broadcast ending a linear
number of vectors where they claim that
these parties are correct dealers when
they collect the same kind of vectors so
the when they collect two f+ and massing
vectors of a certain broadcast they can
output a prediction of the key so p1 had
broadcast p1 p2 p3 it got from P 3 and P
2 the same thing to a plus 1 we're fine
so it says I predict that q1 is p1 p2
and p3 and I'm going to think that this
is the distribute key for now if there
is a later on a higher vector then we
can go and we're going to output a
bigger key so the actual thing that
happens is that in order to what what
the bigger kid has to be a new kid has
to be bigger than a previous one so the
predictions only increase in size as a
result we're going to have at most F
predictions from 2's plus 1 dealers up
to 3 plus 1 dealers
so why does this work well if I made
this prediction that means that I so
those parties deal incorrectly so from
the agreement property of HC FSS I know
that if I wait forever eventually
everyone will see those parts
terminating correctly and tarsals and
ever will make the same prediction it's
just that I'm not sure if my current
prediction is the final prediction or
there will be a bigger key later on so
this is what we call eventual agreement
which means that there exists some key
the ultimate key that everyone's party
will eventually output and never magic
and never change their opinion we don't
know that we'll have the ultimate key we
just know that eventually it will exist
and the second key property of w/kg is
that if you have outputted a key K and
then later on we out with the key J then
the bigger key will contain the previous
one so the predictions only increase in
size okay so that's how with the case it
works and this basically feeds the
eventual better common coin with
basically a threshold signature protocol
and notice that in order for that to
work we need to have a blocking call on
the agreement protocol which means that
if a party is going to invoke give me a
common coin for the sequence number SQ
then is not going to invoke s 2 plus 1
until the until that returns which is
basically anyway what become a binary
agreement uses when it does come on
coins and
how the invincible comic-con works it's
even similar wdk Z you get a prediction
if you get the better and you sign the
sequence number if you haven't
terminated and you get a better
prediction you sign that to your way to
collect massive predictions and you
generate the random value so why does
this work let's say the properties first
of all the termination is pretty simple
eventually we're going to have this
ultimate key what you need randomness
for the binding agreement we're in full
the synchrony so only randomized wrote
the code we solved before for the parts
in synchronous and now we're serving
also for the fully a synchronous yeah so
the termination comes from the eventual
agreement of the wdk G eventually
there's going to be this ultimate key
so eventually every part is going to use
that key to sign the sequence number so
eventually there's going to be
randomness that is consistent with
everything a predictability comes simply
from the VSS you only reveal your secret
only after you are asked for it and
there is not enough malicious parties
and the final key property is the
eventual agreement of the common coin
which says that there is going to be at
most F F sequence numbers for which two
invocations of the common coin will
disagree so it means that there can be
sequence number SQ where IC randomness
number three - and some of this is a
random number five six but this is going
to be only a finite amount of times
actually F in our protocol and why does
this work you see how it works let's see
how the attack works how we get a
disagreement so we have party one and
party tube and their WT EEG is telling
them that they're in key one party 4 is
already on key - that's a mistake a typo
and party three is malicious key one is
smaller thank you - which means that if
a party has in key - it will never go
back the key one okay so how does the
attack work everyone invokes it we see
with the sequence number the party three
is going
like signatures from p1 p2 it will
generate locally signature and have the
random number from q1 then is going to
let P to deliver the new key key to and
because the new key is bigger it will
happily deliver the key and repart is
paid for the same sequence number so
it's going to also sign sq with the new
key and before any we didn't do anything
before so we can easily design the same
sequence number with a new key so we
have a new random value so now the
desert has two random values it can
randomly delivery to whoever he wants
and that's this Agreement basically
parties do not agree on the common coin
now so that's bad but the good thing is
that if this happens then this key is
basically dead so let's go to sequence
number s Q plus 1 p3 is going to do the
same attack so it's going to ask me one
to collect to sign s Q plus 1 it's going
to sign local is 2 plus 1 but there is
no other party that can CL can get this
random value so basically key ones dead
so we lost one key and we have only
finite number of keys as I said there is
from size 2 s plus 1 to size 3 F plus 1
as a result there is only F times this
attack can happen so we need to do is we
stand this F times for tax and
everything will be beautiful afterwards
as I said she cannot be used again for
the next invocation at most opponents
agreement and once you have that then
there's nothing much more to do you can
plug in this common coin to any kind of
a single diagram and you want you can
put in the Braja if you want which is n
cubed we put into Mostafavi is protocol
loop because it's an squared and it
basically gives us a strong common coin
- this F times of this agreement by an
agreement because of weak validity can
actually withstand this kind of
disagreement for a few times so our
binary agreement is basically we'll take
n to the 4th communication words or
communication steps in the bad case when
the adversary's mountain is attacked at
times and and round but for every other
invocation so if you
invoke the polynomial number of times
it's going to be optimal - the F dries
once we have once we have this binary
agreement we're basically going to run
and parallel by an agreements it's one
basically asking the question to have
run is this guy dealing with mystical
correctly did this guy correctly
death a secret and we basically wait for
this and binary grammars terminate if
something ended with one then we put in
the key if you terminate with zero then
we don't put in the key and when all and
terminate we have agreement and we can
plug that in to generate a strong common
coin for Baba and they start running
Baba with the optimal communication
complexity if we run ten squared you
actually amortize the document so that's
it but I just want to talk about what
else we can do with such a conscious
primitive one thing that we can do is
actually create yes the motorist came to
learn how to do Siri
so hence I'll ask a stupid question so
when you plug this result when you plug
this resulting protocol like hot stuff
which has linear set up and you get a
linear you know you don't violate the
linearity but when you plug it within a
protocol like Java wouldn't you use
secret recovery which has quadratic
communication complexity every time and
use existing you know
not even by cutie comedy okay
[Laughter]
build custom agreement yes so basically
we built agreement yes but a slightly
more straightforward approach would be
to use Notepad fault based collective
keys they wouldn't work in full of
synchrony it's not about threshold keys
full of synchrony you need a way to
generate randomness oh no in impartial
synchrony yeah but this would be N
squared you don't need that this will be
N squared can be the bootstrap from that
protocol with no perform keys and on top
of that to the distribute key generation
so in order to generate so you need to
generate that to F plus one key there so
that is where we pay at the end four to
the fourth
it is the AV SS it's not the consensus
so yes but you wouldn't win what
signatures yes so you assume that there
exists bearing base crypto the Ottoman
is where did they assume the score
sensors you mentioned somewhere that
here you will do usually threshold
signature
you only do three score signatures at
the eventual perfect common coin so
you've done the secret sterling you have
secrecy that is yes exactly and once
week it's when you get the disagreement
points but when it's when you have
consistency that's how I call it when
every part has in the same set of
dealers that's when the coin is strong
so so you basically optimistically hope
that you agree and then there are times
that you do agree which is when you will
actually generate correct rest or
signatures and times that you don't
agree with basically you will just wait
a bit more for delivery yes I wanted to
mention that another way to understand
it could be that you present the table
like this that starts with connective
age in about 30 years ago maybe yeah and
then you have to increment the
improvements of the communication of
complexity and around complexity of
message complexities because this is
computation insecure those so this is a
competition only in random Oracle model
lacking in information theoretic and I
think the state of where there is n to
the sixth not sure I think it was two
years ago at ports
yeah
so it's one more thing in that is it
because like Christians paper from the
scissors where they use any agreement on
a subset type of protocol that could be
included on their big dkg to get the
similar thing but maybe your new
protocol has really small constant for
enter miles so we can we can take big
PKG subset so that given and keys we
agree on a subset of those Enki yes sir
Sir we can't use any binary agreement
that no threshold signatures but that
would be I think an v log and basically
it wouldn't be because the best case is
connected up in with Christian services
which send to the fourth and if you run
and they don't serve randomness like in
my case in the wig decay D in the 80kg
basically that we all serve the same
common coin in the Canadian protocol you
need to generate fresh randomness for
every agreement protocol so if you run
in parallel of those it goes into the
fifth and the Logan comes from the
exponential number of termination so
this would work what would been faithful
again and wouldn't amortize
we're gonna take it offline so that I
can date and a wide world
yeah so cool stuff that we can do one is
we can do actually asynchronous payment
sandals which means that their payment
channels that are secure and congestion
they're secure and censorship they can
even be secured under temporary Forks
not long Forks but if you fork a couple
of blocks isn't good enough and also we
can use it to do confidential data
exchange over the blockchain
let's first accountable it's dynamic and
like I have citations I guess that would
be online if you want to take this work
out yes so if you know how payment
centers work you have this Delta time
that the dispute transaction has to show
up if your blockchain is congested it
might not show up because there are the
transactions and it's insecure this
protocol is secure even in that case
under congestion you can it can take
arbitrarily long to put the final the
closing transaction I'm saying
I can explain more of that there's also
the paper who can take it to flying how
are you okay okay yeah so I mean we'd
answer any more questions welcome thank
you okay so I don't mind the next block